as individuals
we often feel alone in our thoughts
unseen in our behaviors and unheard in
our words
i'm dr millicent rose i'm a therapist
and a professor of clinical psychology
today we will be courageously sharing
the things that we often think we're
going through by ourselves
i'm going to read off a list of
statements for each statement please
stand and raise your umbrella if you
agree
stay seated if you disagree
i sometimes feel like i have to wear
makeup so i don't get told
i look tired
i grew up with a lot of dark guys i've
seen on videos that people have
commented so then i
started using like concealer on the eyes
for the videos i actually don't know if
it's about what other people tell me
more than just like what i feel about
myself once i hit 30 i'm just like oh no
i'm scared of looking oh let me put
something on his face
i have given someone a fake number or a
fake name
sometimes people don't understand that
no means no
i just did it with people
i have felt nervous when being pulled
over
hell yeah
they do come off a little bit aggressive
and it kind of
agitates me a little bit and i do become
a little bit nervous i feel like i'm not
allowed to ask
questions or advocate for myself or even
question what's going on at all
any speaking that's not just yes sir is
not allowed
that is really uncomfortable and scary
i have hesitated or am uncomfortable
displaying pda
with my significant other
with my current partner who is trans and
non-binary
especially when traveling things can
feel very
not safe i got like spit at with my
ex-girlfriend they were like get the
rope and
ever since then i've been just terrified
to do anything even when i'm in areas
that i know
are really accepting i think it's more
so having kid myself for so long that
i'm still getting comfortable
being able to show it in public i have
been bullied online for my identity
people like to tell me that i'm not
mexican enough or that i'm not latina
enough on the internet that's been
something that i struggle with sometimes
i've like recently started putting like
my eating disorder journey on my social
media and i've gotten so much like
your eating disorder isn't that bad or
like you don't look like you have an
eating disorder anymore which is like
really damaging i have hesitated
speaking my native language
in front of others
here in l.a it's been more accepting but
even so when i go
to other states i feel very
uncomfortable like calling my mom and
talking spanish
deep in my head i'm afraid that like
they're gonna say some
comment or do anything worse my college
graduation
that was only like three years ago my
mom told me that they were speaking in
spanish with my family
and someone turned around and told them
that they should be speaking english
how about me in the navy and i'm not
going to say only white state is a there
was also some white washed latinos
that will turn to us but like this is
america you do not speak
spanish here you know go back to mexico
i'm like i'm dominican
and second of all we in thailand
can i say something about that i've like
had a conversation with my mom who's
chinese and grew up speaking pretty much
only chinese and tagalog
my mom said that like her family
emigrated here they were just forced to
learn english
it's just really sad to me because i
would love to know how to speak it like
it's just like we're losing that
culture like every generation it just
sucks i have been hesitant or
uncomfortable
around food
do you want to say anything man i'm just
asking because i will
yeah you can okay there's a lot of
stereotypes and
guilt and shame and just being out like
eating like a cheeseburger when i know
like
my smaller friends can be sitting there
with like a whole table of food
but no one will ever question them but
i so much as put one thing that is
not healthy in my mouth and that's why
i'm fat that's why i'm made how i
am and that's why i'm going to die
before everybody else
i am not allowed to donate blood
i'm anemic and i'm also underweight so i
can't donate blood
i have a brother who has a heart
condition so he's in constant need of
blood transfusions
i can't help my brother because of that
i can't donate blood either due to the
rule about men having sex with other men
i actually ran the blood drives
in high school and i mean at the time i
would like do the
screenings so it was always
uncomfortable being like i'm like you
but
unfortunately according to rules of
our government you cannot give blood it
still was always in the back of my mind
i won't be able to donate by the time
that i
finally can so repeat after me because
of who i love
because of who i love my blood isn't
good enough my blood isn't good enough
i have often kept my drink covered with
my hand
at a bar
you just never know my biggest fear is
just someone slipping something into my
drink
even when i enjoy myself even when i
enjoy myself and i drink
and i drink i have to fear being
violated i have to fear being violated
i have thought about my skin color when
i walk into a room
you know how you look like first you
already assume how other people are
going to perceive you
it's just the way that your world is
going into like this newer phase of my
life of house hunting
really having to worry about everything
from my skin tone to the way i dressed
just to get a chance at them considering
me
i have hesitated before joining a
religious organization
because of my identity
i just grew up in a really religious
household surrounded by a lot of very
religious
people who i know didn't accept who i
was even before i knew who i was so
i have literally no inclination to
want to ever be a part of a religious
organization because of that my dad
who's black my mom
is white we lived in a very
predominantly white area
everything was fine i was going to
sunday school and my dad's brother
passed away
at the end they invite you up to give
your condolences and like
nobody went up to my dad and said
anything to him
and we were the only like people of
color religion is supposed to be about
community and then it
so clearly isn't has kept me away a
little bit
i feel uncomfortable wearing a hoodie up
at night
oh yeah definitely when you walk around
with a hoodie and you're black and
you're
you're a dude you're already perceived
as a threat you gotta think twice
whether you're walking around with a
hoodie especially a black hoodie
i have had to worry about my family
being targeted because of their race
so my parents don't know any english
they're from puerto rico
fully american citizens yet every time
they come for a fun vacation
everything is a challenge and they live
in constant fear of being targeted i
feel sad for them because they
worked extra hard for us so we wouldn't
have to go through it
i just think about how they tried my
parents
to really do well in this country to be
constantly thinking in the back of my
mind that if they speak spanish
or if someone knows that they're mexican
or immigrants that they're gonna be
you know harassed in a certain way like
hearing my mom tell me that on my own
graduation like someone told her to
speak english
i think that's what keeps me up at night
is i worry about them
huge deep breaths
me and my sisters were never really
worried about us because we're like
white passing enough or whatever but my
mom
and my asian grandparents it was like so
scary when there was like so many hate
crimes going on and even like
in the grocery store hearing people talk
about like the chinese virus or whatever
and just like worrying like
if somebody was going to do something to
somebody i loved it's it's really scary
i have texted a friend my whereabouts
just in case
i would always drop the location for my
friends and like let them know exactly
where we were going
what type of car he had if he was
driving me there are so many
missing black women that no one cares to
look for or find
so i think it's been like so ingrained
into my brain that like you need to do
those things no matter what i think
generally when i go anywhere alone i'm
just scared and i don't really have a
specific thing that i'm scared of
can i ask you all to repeat after me my
gender my gender
makes me vulnerable making me vulnerable
i have been followed in a store
because they were afraid i was going to
steal something
definitely yes it's frustrating because
i know where they're following me
because they think i'm going to steal
even by my own people that's the sad
part about it
i have needed to explain my sexuality to
my parents
i'm like very fortunate that they were
very loving and welcoming
i think they still were like oh like
what took so long and it's just like
you're expected to come out
and have it be like a whole thing i just
wanted to bring someone back still
working on it we'll get there
while we all are very different we have
a lot of similar experiences
i think based on the questions that were
asked i'm just hoping that
people with privilege realize that this
could be somebody's walk of life
and take that with consideration an open
conversation about these things
will better help each other to help each
other even in
places like this where things feel
destructive one of the things that we
are entitled to
is to hold on to hope that there is
going to be some
enlightenment there is going to be
alleviation and that
being confronted with negative feelings
is not going to be the thing that
destroys us
it's one more thing to make us a little
bit more stronger
to help us understand ourselves in the
world around us today i saw
a lot of good in the people here and i
hope that they're able to take this
experience and make it transformative
[Music]
you